because i have my own show i have a
responsibility to say things that people
need to know that aren't being said it's
a cool opportunity that i don't take
lightly there are very big obvious
truths that no one wants to say on tv
but i will so
i can't believe i have to say this but
you matter even though florida passed
the don't say gay bill that prohibits
teachers from talking about gay people
in their classrooms you matter
children who are gay shouldn't sit in
school wondering if there are other
people like them they shouldn't be made
to feel like there is something wrong
with them and kids with two moms or two
dads shouldn't be made to feel like
there is something wrong with their
family there is nothing wrong with being
gay and cutting off an entire part of
our community will hurt us all in the
long run now they can stop us from
saying gay they can try to put all the
restrictions on you they want they can
try to get people to be scared of you or
grossed out by you and i'm sorry but it
doesn't change the fact that you matter
and another thing
i can't believe i have to say this but
stop selling luggage at the airport if
i'm at the airport i already have
luggage
you think i just showed up with some
loose t-shirts and a hundred dollars
you think i'm walking around with two
handfuls of socks like where can i put
these where can i put these
shut down that luggage store at the
airport and replace it with a store that
sells something useful like vodka
and uh
and i can't believe i have to say this
but
it is wrong for there to be hundreds of
new anti-trans bills being introduced
across america this year it is not okay
to make trans children feel unsafe they
deserve our protection but it's a lot
easier to get people to vote republican
by making up problems like immigrants
are taking our jobs or black people are
going to come get you and i'm so sorry
that our trans community has become the
latest boogeyman you deserve better and
you matter
also i can't believe i have to say this
but
don't play music out loud on public
transportation
i get that you can't wait till you get
home to listen to thong song by cisco
i get it the most but that doesn't mean
we all want to be magically transported
to 1999 with you either buy headphones
or sit in silence and question your life
choices like a normal person if you
think it's fine to make us all listen to
your personal dj session you're wrong
we're wrong wrong wrong
i can't believe i have to say this but
think pieces about whether we should
teach school children about queer people
or gender identity are not okay
who you are should never be up for
debate the only thing those think pieces
make me think is that the person who
wrote them is a bigot
and finally i can't believe i have to
say this but
crocs are ugly
they look like colanders for your feet
they look like two little buckets that
lost a fight with a hole punch i cannot
believe someone tricked y'all into
wearing them
people are like nurses wear them because
they're comfortable well i think nurses
deserve better
i didn't bang on pots and pans every
night for nurses that have wet socks
that's not right
now i thought people were wearing them
because they cost a dollar but
do you know they cost more than a dollar
these cost 35
these cost 54.99
and these cost 625
dollars
man
for 625 dollars you can wear no shoes
hop on my back and i'll take you
wherever you want to go
so
there you go the don't say gay bill is
trash luggage should not be sold at the
airport you deserve to feel safe get
headphones we can see through your
hateful articles cracks and most of all
and i can't stress this enough you
matter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you